bonjour à toutes et à tous j'ai une
excellente nouvelle à vous annoncer
depuis quelques mois je vous propose des
vidéos sur youtube et les réseaux
sociaux qui explique avec bonheur et
rigueur le monde qui nous entoure
car j'adore apprendre mais j'aime aussi
transmettre le savoir est pour moi comme
un énorme gâteau qui encore plus debout
quand on le partage et j'ai le plaisir
de vous annoncer la naissance des
piqûres yeux c'est le nom de ma chaîne
du savoir sur youtube est aussi le nom
d'une communauté la vôtre la nôtre celle
de toutes celles et ceux qui pensent que
la curiosité n'est pas un vilain défaut
chaque semaine je vais désormais vous
proposer plusieurs rendez vous les
vidéos des échanges avec vous chers
répit curieux et de nouveaux visages je
vais bien sûr vous parler de science
mais aussi d'histoire de géographie
d'environnement je vais vous faire
découvrir des lieux des métiers et
leproux lise de notre vie quotidienne
l'origine par exemple des expressions de
la langue française de nos aliments de
nos coutumes
epicure yeux c'est le goût du savoir je
vous y attends
promis on va se régaler
vous ne loupez aucune vidéo abonnez vous
et activer la petite cloche
[Musique]